RONALD SMITH: Well, we were
talking about mixing in the
atmosphere.
And we did two types
of analysis.
First of all, we assumed that
there was a turbulence in the
atmosphere that would mix gases
or particles into a
larger and larger volume.
And we did three problems
like that.
One was adding a material
to a confined valley.
The second was adding material
to the atmosphere in an
unconfined situation.
Where the turbulence would act
to spread that material out
progressively with time.
So the longer the time had
elapsed, the larger would be
the volume into which the
material had mixed.
And the more dilute it
would have become.
The third problem we did was
adding material at a steady
rate into an atmosphere that has
both turbulence and wind.
In that case, the added material
forms a kind of a
plume downwind of the source
point, spreading out as it
goes horizontally and
vertically, and becoming more
dilute for that reason.
It spreads out into more
and more volume as
it moves down wind.
So we did problems like
those three last time.
And then I went on to start to
talk about the role of the
temperature gradient
in mixing.
It turns out that the
temperature profile in the
earth's atmosphere plays a very
important role in how
material mixes into
the atmosphere.
And that arises because under
certain circumstances, a
parcel of polluted air will be
able to rise and spread into a
large volume aloft.
In other situations, that parcel
if it tries to rise,
may fall right back down to
where it started and be unable
to mix vertically.
And this has to do with the
vertical temperature gradient.
So I'm going to pick up
on that theme today.
But if there are any questions
on it at this
point just call out.
All right.
So this is the diagram that I
had on the board a little bit
differently.
But I was defining atmospheric
stability as the resistance to
vertical motion.
And this is a plot of
temperature on the x-axis
versus height on the y-axis.
And we put on there a reference
line, which this
author has written DALR.
That's the dry adiabatic
lapse rate.
I call it just the adiabatic
But it's good to call it the
dry adiabatic lapse rate
because inside a cloud, that
takes on a different slope.
So this is one when you're
outside a cloud, there's no
water vapor condensing.
So we'll call it the dry
adiabatic lapse rate.
And all these other curves are
possible, actual atmospheric
lapse rates.
On Tuesday, maybe
the temperature
decreases aloft like that.
On Wednesday, maybe
it's like that.
The next day, maybe
It might even be like that.
In other words, from day to day
from hour to hour, you're
going to have different
actual lapse rates.
And in each case, we're going
to want to compare that with
this reference curve, the dry
adiabatic lapse rate.
And as I discussed last time,
all of these that are less
horizontal, that is more
vertical or more to the right,
than the dry adiabatic
lapse rate, are going
to be called stable.
Because if you lift a parcel in
the air, it's going to be
cooling at a rate of 9.8
degrees per kilometer.
It's going to end up--
if I lift it from there to
there, it's new temperature is
going to be here.
And that's going to be in all
cases colder than the
environment into which
it's been lifted.
If it's colder, it's going to
want to sink back down to
where it came from.
So we call that stable.
The unstable case is where you
have a very strong decrease in
temperature with height.
Then if you lift a parcel along
the dry adiabatic lapse
rate, it's actually getting
warmer than it's environment.
So when it's been lifted a
little bit, it finds itself
warmer than it's local
environment.
That means it's buoyant.
And it's going to
rise further.
That's the unstable situation.
So you'll want to practice
sketching these diagrams up to
be sure that you always get the
right answer about what
the parcel is going to do.
You might want to practice
lifting a parcel as well as
pushing a parcel downwards.
And in all cases, you should be
able to recover this basic
idea that the atmosphere is
either stable or unstable
depending on its lapse rate
compared with the reference
value of the adiabatic
lapse rate.
Questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: Is the dry adiabatic
lapse rate always 9.8?
PROFESSOR: Yes, in the earth's
atmosphere, it's always 9.8 It
turns out to be the ratio of the
surface gravity, 9.81, to
the heat capacity of constant
pressure for
air, which is 1,004.
So as long as we're talking
about planet earth, the
adiabatic lapse rate is
always 9.8, the dry
adiabatic lapse rate.
Now if there is moisture
present, then
it's a different value.
STUDENT: And that's
in what units?
PROFESSOR: That would be 9.8
would be in degrees Celsius
per kilometer.
OK.
Now I want to apply this
to some situations.
And let me darken this
a little bit
so you can see that.
I want to walk through a typical
diurnal cycle, a day
night cycle.
And today would be a perfect
example of this, clear sky
overnight, clear sky
during the day.
It's going to work very
much like I described
in these four panels.
So at 6:00 AM this morning, you
have built up a nocturnal
boundary layer.
This is temperature versus
height plotted here with the
purple curve.
Notice that there's a positive
lapse rate in the lower part
of the atmosphere in
the early morning.
The ground has been cooling off
all during the night by
radiating infrared radiation
to space.
That's drawn heat out of the
lowest few meters of the
atmosphere.
And has produced that
positive lapse rate.
You can call that
an inversion.
In fact, I'm going to call it
a surface level inversion.
It's an inversion located
right at just above the
earth's surface.
And that typically happens
overnight on a clear night
when the radiation can leave,
can escape the earth's
atmosphere without
hitting clouds.
So remember where that
fit on the diagram.
Just to go back.
That's this.
So that's a very stable
atmosphere.
And turbulence will
be suppressed.
There will be very little
turbulence.
Very little vertical motion.
And the air will just lie
there quietly in layers.
The wind, which has continued
to blow aloft all during the
day and night, will be
calm at the surface.
Because without the turbulence,
there's no way to
mix that momentum down to the
surface of the earth.
Remember the wind aloft
doesn't feel the
diurnal cycle very much.
So it blows day and
night typically.
That depends more on the local
weather systems and so on.
But the winds often go calm at
night at the very surface
because of this lack of
turbulence to mix
the momentum down.
You must have noticed this
if you're a camper
or an outdoors person.
You will have noticed that very
often, wind decreases to
calm at night.
And then picks up the
next morning.
I noticed it myself this
morning, for example, sitting
at home 7:00 in the morning,
looked out, none of the leaves
were moving.
And then around 8:00 or 8:30,
suddenly the leaves begin to
move finally.
Because the earth had heated up
the atmosphere, convection
began, and you start to get the
wind being brought down.
And the wind starts to move
at the earth's surface.
So let's go to that
next stage then.
So 11:00 AM, the sun is
heating the earth.
If the earth is getting warm
then it's putting heat into
the lowest few meters
of the atmosphere.
And that's going to bring that
lapse right around this way,
hotter below and cooler above.
And that's going to fit into
one of these categories,
probably that one or that one.
If it goes unstable, convection
is going to begin.
And that's what they've
drawn here.
The heat being provided by the
surface of the earth produces
a strong negative lapse rate,
pushes the atmosphere into an
unstable state, and
convection begins.
The air begins to turn over.
When it does that, it brings
some of that general wind down
to the earth's surface.
That trend continues.
By 3:00 in the afternoon, that
convection layer has grown to
a kilometer or a kilometer
and 1/2 deep.
Very often there are cumulus
clouds with their flat bases
right at the bottom of that--
or right at the top of that
convective layer.
So this afternoon, if you look
out, and you see cumulus
clouds, you'll know that
this has happened.
And that cloud base is right at
the top of the convection
boundary layer.
And then when we get to
the evening again,
the sunlight stops.
The earth's surface cools
with infrared radiation.
And you start to build
up that surface level
inversion once again.
So the cycle just repeats day
and night, day and night.
Any questions on this?
Yes.
STUDENT: I'm still a little
confused about why the
inversion one is the
stable atmosphere?
PROFESSOR: The question is why
is the inversion so stable?
Well, think of it this way.
When you lift a parcel, it
gets colder with height.
And yet if you have a background
lapse rate like
this, the environment
is actually
getting warmer with height.
So you're getting both
things working
in the stable direction.
The parcel is getting colder
because it's expanding and
cooling adiabatically.
Yet, you're pushing it into
an environment which is
progressively warmer
and warmer.
So almost certainly, that parcel
is going to find itself
colder than its new
environment.
And it's going to want to sink
back to where it came from.
So the reason why we say very
stable is because both the
adiabatic expansion and the
movement into a new
environment both work to make
the parcel want to return to
where it came from.
Any questions about
the diurnal cycle?
Yes.
STUDENT: Is it just the Earth's
surface temparature
that drives it?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
That's right.
So remember the sun's radiation
is coming through.
The lower part of the atmosphere
is generally
transparent.
And so the sun's radiation is
coming through and hitting the
earth's surface, warming
it up during the day.
And that heat is then
transferred immediately from
the earth's surface to the
first meter or so of the
atmosphere.
And that's what causes that
lapse rate to tip over.
Because you're adding heat
from the bottom.
Here, you're subtracting heat
from the bottom, giving you
this inversion.
So you have the earth's
surface playing a very
important role in this.
That's a good point.
Now you could also get what's
called an elevated inversion.
And that's what's
pictured here.
Whenever you have slow subsiding
air up through the
troposphere, as you would, for
example, as you do today,
whenever you have high pressure
and clear skies, you
can be pretty certain that there
is very slow subsidence.
The air is slowly descending
through the troposphere.
Well, that air cannot descend
through the earth's surface
because the earth's
surface is solid.
So it has to spread out.
And you get warming here but
not warming at the surface.
So you end up in this subsidence
situation creating
an elevated inversion.
If I plotted the temperature,
it would probably look like
decreasing, then increasing,
and decreasing again in an
elevated inversion.
An inversion of this type
too is very stable.
It's almost impossible
to mix air across it.
So any pollution put in beneath
will be trapped,
almost as if it were
a rigid lid.
But it's not.
It's air above and air below.
But it's warm air above.
And therefore parcels that try
to rise up through here find
themselves too cold,
too dense.
And they sink back down.
And they can't mix that
pollutant up into the free
atmosphere.
Most of the pollution episodes
are connected with these
elevated inversions.
For example, some of the most
famous polluted cities in the
world: Los Angeles; Santiago,
Chile; Mexico
City; Beijing in China.
You see pictures of them here.
In each case, in this case,
you can see the inversion.
Here you can see it as well.
There is, an elevated inversion
trapping that
pollutant, preventing it from
being diluted up into the rest
of the free atmosphere.
So inversions go together with
air pollution episodes.
They are very closely linked.
If the inversion was not there,
this pollution could
just quickly mix up into
the free atmosphere.
It would be much more
completely diluted.
And you wouldn't have the
concentration of sulfur
dioxide, and NO, and ozone,
and so on that you have in
these polluted episodes.
I want to give you three
examples of rather famous gas
releases that kind of illustrate
some of the
physical principles I'm
discussing today.
The first two are going to be
brief emissions of toxic gases
that just happen to take
place at night.
Now this was a problem.
If the same thing had happened
during the day, it would not
have been so much
of a problem.
But at might remember, you've
got this stable, nocturnal
surface level inversion that
prevents vertical mixing.
And therefore, if you emit
something at night, it's not
going to be diluted.
It's going to stay in high
concentrations close to the
earth's surface.
So unfortunately, these first
two cases, Lake Nyos and
Bhopal, were both night
time releases.
Here's the Lake Nyos one.
It's a lake in Africa.
It's a deep, volcanic lake that
over a period of months
or years, because the water had
been circulating through
volcanic rocks beneath, had
built up a high dissolved load
of carbon dioxide.
It was dissolved in the liquid
just like it is when you buy a
can of Coke.
Most of the CO2 is dissolved
in the liquid.
And then for some reason, and
no one to this day knows
exactly why it happened or why
it happened at that point,
that CO2 one night came out of
solution to form bubbles, rose
to the surface of the lake,
and then spread
out across the landscape.
Remember CO2 has the molecular
weight of 44.
Air has 29.
So it's a denser gas than air.
That's going to make it want
to hug the surface as well.
And because it was a
night, there was a
surface level inversion.
That prevented any
vertical mixing.
So the CO2 stayed in a
concentrated form and just
spread laterally away from the
lake killing thousands of
cattle but also hundreds of
people as well as they slept.
This layer of CO2 just slid over
them and then basically
suffocated them.
Because you can't breathe
carbon dioxide.
I want to make the point again
that this would not have
happened if the emission had
occurred during the day.
There would have been enough
mixing, enough convection to
dilute that carbon dioxide.
And you wouldn't have
had those deaths.
The Bhopal incident in India,
some 25 ago, was a Union
Carbide plant making what's
called MIC, methyl isocyanate.
It sounds pretty ugly,
and it is.
There were some storage
tanks that leaked.
And the normal systems for
capturing that leak were not
functioning properly.
And it happened to then get
released into the lower
atmosphere unfortunately
at night.
So rather than getting mixed and
convectively diluted, it
spread out as a layer to the
surrounding houses and
hundreds of people were killed
as they were overtaken by this
layer of methyl isocyanate.
And that was a big deal at
the time, front page Time
magazine and so on.
I was in India a few months
after that and
took a lot of abuse.
Because this incident started
an intensive ten years of
anti-Americanism in India
because of this incident.
And it's still remembered
today.
If you talk to people from India
and mention Bhopal, they
will talk about how the evil
US chemical corporations
caused this terrible accident
in their country.
And they have a good point.
But there was some luck
involved too,
bad luck that is.
Because the release happened to
occur at night rather than
during the day
So Chernobyl, a different kind
of situation; it was the
meltdown of a nuclear
power plant.
It lasted for several days.
So it's not a question
of day versus night.
In this case, the warm
radioactive gases released
from that plant did lift upwards
into the atmosphere
and then the wind carried
it to great distances.
So maybe the drawback, perhaps
the drawback of having a
daytime release is
it gets diluted.
But it also gets up in the
atmosphere where the winds can
carry it to a greater
distance.
And if the substance is diluted
to a safe level by
that mixing process that's OK.
But in this case, there was so
much radioactive material that
even though it was spread over
large parts of eastern Europe
and northern Europe, it still
caused damaging levels of
radioactivity spread
by the winds.
This was mostly radioactive
iodine that then settles on
the grasses and people get
it into their system.
And they end up with radioactive
induced diseases.
Same thing happened in this
country during the nuclear
testing episode back in the 50's
and early 60's when we
were doing, believe
it or not, aerial
nuclear tests in Nevada.
Where in mid latitudes, the
winds are normally west to
east in these latitudes.
So this shows some of the
radioactive regions that were
found coming from aerial
explosions and the wind
carried that radioactive
material from west to east.
Any questions on this?
The point here is just to talk
about what happens when you
put substances into
the atmosphere.
How does it get mixed around?
What conditions control that?
Forest fires are
a good example.
You're burning biomass.
You're producing smoke.
And depending on the atmospheric
conditions, that
may hug the surface
and move downwind
like it's shown there.
Or it might rise to a higher
altitude and then move across
through the atmosphere
without polluting
the very lowest levels.
Eventually it'll fall back
down to the surface.
But if it's hot enough material,
it will rise and get
carried away some kilometers
above the earth's surface.
Those are the two
possibilities with forest fires.
Smokestacks are the same way.
Now a smokestack is designed to
get this smoke released at
a point that's above any surface
level inversion.
So then it'll be carried
quickly into the free
atmosphere and become
rapidly diluted.
So that protects the local
environment from the negative
effects of the smoke and
the air pollution.
But it does, of course, mean
that now the material will be
carried to greater distances
because you've put it up into
a level where the winds
are stronger.
And it will be carried
off downwind.
As in our little problem we
did last time with a point
source and the wind
carrying it away.
During the first Gulf War,
the Kuwaiti oil fires.
You see them here burning
off patches of
oil, producing smoke.
They're rising.
Typically they're so hot that
they'll rise a couple of
kilometers up in
the atmosphere.
And then they'll level out.
And they'll move horizontally
under the action of the wind.
In just a moment, I'll talk
about how you can estimate how
far these things rise before
they start to spread downwind.
Here's an aerial photo of these
black, sooty, smoky
plumes from the oil fires being
carried away by the wind.
So the most recent, interesting
example we've had
of this are these wonderful
Iceland volcanoes.
I say wonderful because while
they caused a lot of damage,
they were amazing to see.
The pictures were really,
quite remarkable.
Here's an example.
You can't make out the
mountain very well.
But there's a volcanic plume
coming out of it.
It's rising to a certain
level and then
spreading out downwind.
And I'd like you to think for a
minute about exactly why the
plume looks like that?
So I pulled off a balloon
sounding for Iceland.
It wasn't at the moment
of that eruption.
It was just from a
couple days ago.
But I think the story
is the same.
Here's temperature on
this axis versus
height on that axis.
And the temperature is
the black curve here.
And the blue curves are that
reference line we've been
using, the dry adiabatic--
sorry green curves are the
dry adiabatic lapse rate.
So if I put in an air parcel
at 40 degrees Celsius.
The air temperature at the
ground is only on that day
about plus four Celsius.
That air parcel is going to be
hotter and therefore buoyant.
It's going to rise.
As it rises, it's going
to cool adiabatically.
And eventually, it will come to
the same temperature as the
environment.
At that point, it will have
the same density and
temperature as the
environment.
It'll stop rising.
And it'll go flat and
just move downwind.
So the point is that a hot,
buoyant plume of air will
rise, cooling as it rises, until
its temperature matches
that of the environment.
And then it has found it's
appropriate level, there's no
reason for it to rise further.
It'll then spread downwind.
Eventually, the particles in
that plume will begin to fall
out gravitationally.
But that could take weeks or
even months to get that
material out.
So when you see a diagram, you
see a picture like this, just
be aware that if that
air were even hotter
it would rise higher.
If it were cooler, it'll rise
less high and spread out at
this level.
That elevation is being
controlled by the properties
of the air that's
being emitted.
Questions on that?
Yes.
STUDENT: What if there was wind
right at the bottom--
right above the volcano?
Would it go that--?
PROFESSOR: The question
is what if there
is wind at the surface?
Well, there may have
been some wind.
Let's go back to that.
It looks like it's going
straight up.
But if there was a wind down
here of course that would tilt
it as it rose.
Let's say the wind is from left
to right in this diagram.
That would tilt this plume.
It already has a
bit of a tilt.
But still it would rise to this
level and then move off
horizontally.
It'll always follow the wind.
But it will continue to rise
until it has neutral buoyancy.
And then it'll stay
at that level.
Was there another question?
No, OK.
Sandstorms can do
a similar thing.
The winds can pick up--
this is off the west
coast of Africa.
The wind has picked up some dust
off the Sahara desert and
carried it out over the ocean.
And turbulence is keeping
it aloft.
Eventually, gravitational
settling will make that stuff
fall back on to the
ocean's surface.
So you see the same factors
at play in this natural
phenomenon of just picking up
dust from the earth's surface.
I want to switch gears and begin
to talk about moisture
in the atmosphere.
And we'll continue this subject
next time as well.
So you should be reading in your
book now about clouds and
precipitation and water vapor
in the atmosphere.
And this material will be on
the examination as well.
So I want to start with
some definitions.
And I haven't written
them all out here.
Because I think your book
does a good job on this.
Or maybe you already
know these.
I'm going to run through
them very quickly.
But you should be aware of
each of these six things.
They're all alternative ways of
describing how much water
vapor you have in the air.
So in fact, if I know any one of
these, I can compute, or in
some other way determine,
the other five.
But you should be familiar
with all six of these.
So one measure of how much water
vapor you have in the
atmosphere is the partial
pressure.
What contribution are the water
vapor molecules making
to the total pressure
of the air?
It's probably only a
very tiny fraction.
If the pressure in this room is
at 1,013 millibars, maybe
only five or six of those
millibars are due to the water
vapor molecules.
But you should be able
to compute that.
The saturation vapor pressure
is not actually a measure of
how much you have. It's the
maximum amount you can have.
When you get that amount of
water vapor and try to add
more, the excess will
condense out.
And this is a strong function
of temperature.
I'll be talking about that
in just a moment.
The dew point is a measure of
how much water vapor you have.
If you cool the air down to the
dew point then water vapor
will begin to condense.
So it's the temperature at which
water vapor begins to
condense out.
The specific humidity is the
ratio of the mass of water
vapor to the mass of air.
It's like a mixing ratio,
grams per kilogram, or
kilograms per kilogram.
For every kilogram of air,
how much water has
been mixed into it?
That's the specific humidity.
The relative humidity is the
ratio of the partial pressure
of water vapor to the
saturation value.
It's the ratio of
this to this.
It's the relative humidity.
That's important because that
tells you how close you are to
saturation.
If you're at 50% relative
humidity, that means you could
add twice as much water vapor
and just then be bringing it
to the saturation state.
If you're at a 100% relative
humidity, there's already just
as much water vapor
as can be held.
If you added anymore, you would
have to condense out.
And you'll recall the wet bulb
depression from the lab
exercise you did.
One way of measuring how much
water vapor you have is to
have a wet bulb and a dry
bulb thermometer.
If they read the same, you know
there's no evaporation
from the wet bulb, which means
the humidity is 100%.
If they read differently, that
means the air is somewhat dry
is able to evaporate water
from the wetted wick.
And that'll give you a different
temperature for the
two thermometers.
That's the wet bulb
depression.
And from that you can compute
any of these others, except
for that one.
You can compute those
other four.
Any questions on these measures
of water vapor?
I'm kind of assuming that you
know this already from a high
school physics or
chemistry class.
So this is probably a little
bit of a review here.
Some other definitions
we're going to need--
Condensation is when you change
water vapor to liquid.
Or sometimes we use that
word also when we're
condensing it to ice.
But usually it's used when
we condense it to liquid.
Evaporation is the
reverse of that.
It's when you take water in the
liquid form and evaporate
it, put it back in
the vapor state.
When you do either of those
things, there is heat either
taken in or released.
And that heat is called the
latent heat of condensation.
When you're evaporating water,
you have to put heat in.
When you're condensing water,
heat comes out.
I want to make a clear
distinction between cloud
droplets and raindrops.
A cloud droplet is a typical
water drop that you see that
makes up a cloud.
You look up at a cloud in the
sky, it is composed of
millions of cloud droplets.
We put the little suffix "let"
there to remind us
that these are small.
A typical cloud droplet is about
ten microns in diameter.
Ten microns in diameter.
A micron, remember, is a
millionth of a meter.
A raindrop is a kind
of liquid drop you
find falling to earth.
And they are typically about
a millimeter in size.
In other words, about a
hundred times larger.
There is a factor of about one
hundred in the size of these
two different droplets.
Questions so far on
these definitions?
Supercooled liquid water is
liquid water that has been
cooled down below the normal
freezing point.
Freezing point for fresh water
is zero degrees Celsius.
And yet in the atmosphere, we
often find liquid water at
temperatures of minus
ten, minus 20,
even minus 30 Celsius.
It's in the liquid state, and
yet it is below the normal
freezing point of water.
We call water in that state
supercooled liquid water.
It wants to freeze.
It's at a temperature where
it should be frozen.
But it needs some kind of a
trigger to get the freezing
process started.
And it turns out that plays a
big role in the generation of
precipitation, as I'll be
describing next time.
And then this word riming, which
is what happens when a
super cooled droplet
hits something.
It wants to freeze.
When it hits an object, it'll
probably freeze upon impact
and stick to the object as
a frozen piece of water--
piece of ice stuck
to the surface.
That is called riming, that
process of having super cooled
water freeze upon impact.
Questions on this?
OK, well, that's a lot
of definitions.
The earth, of course,
is the water planet.
It's covered by large
oceans of water.
The water gets up into the
atmosphere and then in areas
where the air is rising, there
is adiabatic cooling, which
will drop the air temperature,
drop the saturation vapor
pressure, and bring that air--
bring the water vapor in that
air to saturation.
And as that rising air
continues, then the excess
water vapor will condense
to form cloud droplets.
So you see clouds scattered
around in the earth's
atmosphere, you can be almost
certain that every place you
see a cloud, whether it's
large or small, there is
rising air.
And almost every place you find
the sky free of clouds,
there is sinking air.
Because remember, rising
air forms clouds
by adiabatic cooling.
So you look at something like
this, and well, about half of
this is cloud.
And half of it is clear.
Well, that means half
the air is rising.
Half the air is sinking.
The patterns are complicated.
They're connected with a variety
of things like fronts,
thunderstorms, deep convection
over the equator.
But in all cases, it's rising
motion versus sinking motion--
very clearly displayed when you
look at a map like this.
So the key thing to understand
about clouds then, or about
water vapor I should say, is
how do we take air that is
under saturated or sub-saturated
and bring it to
the saturated condition?
And I'm going to run through the
three ways that are active
in the earth's atmosphere
for bringing air to
the saturated state.
Remember you're starting with
air that has a relative
humidity less than a 100%.
And you're asking how can I
bring it to 100% and above?
Probably the most obvious way is
to add moisture, add water
vapor to that air parcel.
I'll show some examples
of that but sea
smoke, contrails, stacks.
Smokestacks sometimes give
off clouds in this way.
And human breath, when you
breathe out on a cold day, you
can create a little
cloud using this
mechanism of adding moisture.
Another ways is to cool
by removing heat.
If you have air that a
sub-saturated, but you remove
heat, you're going to drop
the temperature.
If you drop the temperature,
you're going to drop the
saturation vapor pressure.
And you keep doing that,
you're going to
bring the two together.
You're going to bring the amount
of partial pressure
water vapor together with the
saturation partial pressure.
They'll be equal.
And you'll have the saturated
condition.
The third method is by adiabatic
expansion, that is
by lifting air parcels
up in the atmosphere.
I'm going to give you examples
of all these.
So first, I'll be
adding moisture.
This is something called
sea smoke.
Here's an aircraft carrier
looking out
over the ocean's surface.
It has a very peculiar
appearance.
It appears to be tufts of cloud
torn apart by turbulence
but generally hugging
the ocean's surface.
What's happening there is you
have cold air moving across
the ocean's surface.
And the ocean is warm.
So the ocean is evaporating
its moisture into the
atmosphere.
But then as soon as it does
that, the air being so cold
with that extra water vapor
being added, you've brought
the air to saturation.
And you start to form these
little tufts of cloud or fog.
So that's sometimes
called sea smoke.
It's not smoke.
You're not burning anything.
But because sometimes that's
just the traditional name for
it is sea smoke.
Here's another example from
the Northeastern Labrador
current up off the coast
of Nova Scotia.
Whenever you get cold air moving
over warm water, you
are likely to get
this situation.
Water evaporates from the warm
water, adds moisture to the
cold air, you've brought
that air to saturation.
And little clouds appear
to form on the surface.
A contrail is that way.
A contrail is a contraction
for condensation trail.
And here's an aircraft producing
four contrails, one
from each engine.
So you're burning hydrocarbons
in the aircraft engine.
The chemical byproducts of
this burning are carbon
dioxide and water vapor.
So the exhaust from the engine
is part water vapor.
You're adding it to this cold
air, which was sub-saturated
to begin with.
But you've added enough
water vapor.
So now you've saturated
the air and beyond.
And the excess goes into these
tiny condensed particles
either liquid or ice.
Those are probably liquid as a
result of adding water vapor
to cold air.
Any questions on this?
There's some contrails
from a distance.
Now later on, those contrails
may seem to lose their
contrail appearance.
They may spread out.
They may diffuse.
They may go unstable.
They may even lead to
what looks like
natural cirrus clouds.
But even that more natural
looking cloud, I think, on
this particular day started
out as a contrail.
It just spread a bit by
turbulent diffusion.
If you have a cooling tower
like from a nuclear power
plant, that's not smoke that's
coming out of it.
Tha's just hot, moist air.
You're adding water vapor to a
dry atmosphere bringing it to
saturation and causing what
appears to be a cloud.
Again that's not smoke.
That's just condensed
water in the cloud.
And you, yourself on a chilly
October or November morning,
if you breathe out, the water
vapor that's been added to the
air in your lungs suddenly is
added to the atmosphere
bringing it to saturation.
And the excess condenses
to form the cloud.
So this first one--
Well, I think I'll quit there.
We're going to continue this
theme next time of looking at
how water vapor acts
in the atmosphere.
Our target is to get to a point
where we understand how
clouds and precipitation form.
So be reading ahead in your
book about clouds and
precipitation.